MALE SPEAKER 1: So game
developers in the audience,
round of applause,
how many of you
actually have code
in your game that
tries to track if user A
is doing things differently
than user B?
Little bit?
OK.
MALE SPEAKER 2:
The rest of you, do
you kind of wish you
had code that did that?
Raise your hands.
There we go.
Alright.
That's what I like to see.
MALE SPEAKER 1: The
people who didn't
raise their hands are just,
like, waiting for the show.
MALE SPEAKER 2: They're
just in it for the art.
MALE SPEAKER 1: So listen.
This is clear in our modern
game development ecosystem,
that everything we do right
now is about segmentation
and identification of our
users, so that we can best
classify them and serve them
the experience they want.
Already today we've talked
about identifying whether or not
users respond more to in-game
ads or to in-app purchases.
And properly changing your
code paths to do that.
Or whether or not you
need to target your ad
systems to find different
users and display
different ads to them
at the right time.
This next talk is probably
one of my favorite ones today.
Because for those of
you put your hands up
that you don't have
the code in your game
right now to track your users,
and identify them and figure
out what they want in your
game, this is for you.
Big round of applause for
Mike, Snehal, and Rahul.
[APPLAUSE]
RAHUL OAK: Hi everyone.
Good afternoon.
My name is Rahul Oak.
I'm a product manager on
Google Analytics for apps.
And I have with me
here Snehal and Mike
who are hanging out
in the back right
now so you probably
can't see them.
They're two rock star engineers
on the Google Analytics team.
They actually made sure
I mentioned rock star
in front of their names.
So today I'm here to talk
about turning players
into customers with
Google Analytics.
So what does this
really mean, that you
have a bunch of users
who are using your game?
They love it, they
are highly engaged.
But you kind of want to figure
out which of those are users
and which of those
are customers.
So what we're going
to try and talk
about today is a specific
problem that I think, and I
hope actually, that
resonates with a lot of you.
And then using Google Analytics,
through a series of techniques
and tools, how you
can actually make
this classification between
users and customers,
and hopefully convert more
of your users into customers.
So let's talk about the
big picture a little bit.
And I'm a product manager, I'm
going to use buzzwords a lot.
And one of the buzzwords
that I'm sure you heard a lot
is LTV.
And it's something that the
industry is striving towards.
And this has been a common
theme across the GDC.
As the industry has shifted,
maybe eight years ago in apps,
it was all about how to get
the cheapest users into my app.
But I think the industry
is matured at this point,
and right now you're
not really looking just
to get the cheapest
person that you
can acquire to come
and play a game.
You want someone who is highly
engaged, highly monetized,
and someone who is a
really good customer.
So let's dive into what
this value really means,
how you can measure value.
And I'll talk about this
problem with the help
of a specific chart
that we've put together.
A famous man once said
that all users are equal,
but some are more
equal than others.
Actually I lied, he
didn't say "users".
He mentioned it in the context
of farm animals and not games.
But it applies
fairly well out here.
I'll just walk over
this chart a little bit.
So the y-axis is the
monetization line.
So everyone who is to
the right of the y-axis
is a well-monetized user.
And everyone to the left is not.
Similarly, for the
x-axis, everyone
to the top of the
x-axis are people
who are highly
engaged in your game.
And everyone to
the bottom is not.
Now it's pretty
obvious from this
that the point of your game,
and for any business really,
is to get as many people to the
top right quadrant as possible.
And, especially in the
context of your game,
that means having highly
engaged users who monetize,
who find it worth their
while to actually spend money
to get some value
out of the game.
The folks in the
left top, they're
the guys who are-- the guys
and gals-- who are engaged,
and who you could nurture a
little bit to try and move them
into the right quadrant.
Similarly with the folks
on the right bottom.
There's some potential there.
You want to figure out some
way to get them engaged again.
You hope that they were
engaged at some point.
They spent money,
they went back down.
So what we're
going to try and do
is walk over some
things that we think
you can do with
Google Analytics that
helps you solve
specifically this problem,
and try and get everyone
into the top right quadrant.
And I know that's not really
possible, and in most cases,
that's going to be
sparsely populated.
But we are here to create tools
that help you to try and get
as many people in
there as possible.
So the solution.
Snehal and Mike
are going to talk
about the solution
in a lot more detail.
But before we move forward--
because I realize some of you
may not have used Google
Analytics for apps--
we're going to go over
just very, very quickly,
just to set a baseline here.
This is what a Google
Analytics report
looks like, the
chart on the top,
tables at the bottom,
pretty pictures.
There's some words
that we're going
to use throughout this talk
that I'm going to go over first.
Think of everything in terms
of metrics and dimensions,
so everything that
can be measured.
So sessions and new users and
average session duration, these
are metrics.
Dimensions are things that you
would slice these metrics by.
So in the case of
this report, it
tells you where your
users have come from.
And that's a dimension,
so where they came from,
what kind of device they're
using, what part of the world
they are located in.
And at the very basic level
Google Analytics for apps
is SDKs for iOS and Android.
It's totally free and you
get a lot of amazing reports
to start off with.
It's very, very easy
to get a lot of value
unlocked very quickly with just
two or three lines of code.
And amongst the dozens
of reports that you get,
I'm just going to go
over maybe two or three.
One of the things that you
get, new users, active users,
locations, devices.
These are things that you
can expect from any Analytics
solution.
You care about this stuff.
And you can get
it fairly quickly.
Similarly, one of
the frustrations
that, at least I've experienced
while writing anything,
is once you implement
something, it's out in the wild.
You want to see that it's
working within seconds ideally,
if not minutes.
And the real-time
reports we've got
are really great for that,
because you ship a new version
out and you want to see if
you did a few things right.
And this really helps with that.
Now a little bit of code here.
And these are really
just two lines
in your Android
onStart and onStop.
I didn't put any
iOS code in there.
But it's fairly easy to get
this to work very, very quickly.
And you don't have to
believe me right now.
We have an expo booth and you
can come check it out tomorrow.
We're actually going to do it.
We're going to have
some fun with it.
So the engineers have
come up with a way
to just tell you how easy it is.
It's so easy a product
manager could do it.
So I'm going to
try and get this up
and running in like
five minutes tomorrow.
So while we talk about
just metrics, dimensions,
things you can measure, I
like to think about it broadly
into two things.
One is things which are
very easy for us to gather.
And those are the
things that you saw,
the baseline stuff--
new users, active users,
et cetera, et cetera.
But then there's some things
which only you know about
and you can tell us, which
is important for your game.
And those are things
that require a little bit
more instrumentation.
It's not hard but
it just requires
a little bit of thought.
And to go over this, let
me call Snehal on stage.
SNEHAL THAKKAR: Thanks Rahul.
So as Rahul said, the
tracking is so easy
that even a product
manager can do it.
And we're going to prove it.
Rahul is going to go and prove
it live at our booth tomorrow
and day after, in case
you miss tomorrow.
But there are things that
we could do automatically.
Like every report
that Rahul showed
you shows up automatically
with the two lines
that he just showed you
in a previous slide.
But remember his previous slide?
We want to find users
that are engaged
and that are monetizing.
Well, only you can tell us what
means engaged in your game.
For your game, it may
be achievements, right?
OK, let's say I'm playing a game
and I unlocked an achievement.
Maybe that's engagement for you.
For somebody else it may
be that, oh, I went in
and I fed the character.
We don't know ahead
of time what it is.
But what we would
like to do is give you
a tool to very easily send
that information-- whatever
it is that you choose to send--
to us so that you can then
use that information later on
to analyze whether the users are
engaged, how they're
monetizing, what
do they do before
do they do after,
all the fun stuff.
So let's divide this up.
Basically I divide this
up into three categories.
There is things
that you care about.
Those are like events,
player clicked a button,
somebody unlocked a new
level, somebody upped a level.
Their second category
is monetization.
They had a transaction,
they bought some item,
they bought a set of items.
And the third category
is custom data.
How many people here actually
have their own databases
that back their games?
I mean you collect
your own data, right?
You have all your stuff.
So if you have that
data, wouldn't it
be nice to be able to join
that data along with the data
that Analytics provides?
Well that's where the
custom data comes in.
And we're going to actually
show you how to do that today.
It's easy enough.
We're eventually
going to train Rahul
to do a demo on that stuff too.
Not yet, but we're
getting there.
So how do you track this stuff?
So Analytics actually moves
those things into three groups.
The first set of groups
are what we call Events.
These are basically things
that happened in your game.
The second group is
Revenue, whatever
you monetized to your users.
And the third group
is the custom data,
and we send that over
as Custom Dimensions.
So here is a little
code snippet.
I'm showing the iOS version
of the code snippet,
just so that we can switch
between iOS and Android.
Both of them look very similar
because, at the end of the day,
the data that you need to send
is really the important piece.
The rest of it is just a syntax,
[INAUDIBLE] iOS and Android.
So here, everything
that you see in green
is the things that
you're sending me,
except for the value,
where we actually
chose not to send in a value.
But for every event, you
can categorize your events.
So we allow you to categorize
your events in hierarchies,
so you can actually
keep them in groups.
So for each event you
can send us a category,
you can send us an action,
and you can send us a label.
And if you so choose,
you can associate value.
So for example, if you say, oh,
I have some achievement that
got unlocked, I would like to
associate some value to it,
you could do that.
And then you can use
that value in analysis.
If you choose not
to, no big deal.
Here, we've chosen not
to associate a value.
If you choose not to use
a hierarchy and just say,
well I'm going to only
send you a category, fine.
All of the parameters except
the category are optional.
We need at least one thing
to identify the event by.
The Android version
is exactly similar,
except that it's in the Java
syntax or the iOS syntax.
So once you actually
send us those events,
we can actually show you
flow of how users move around
in your game.
So you could see a report
that actually tells you,
oh, from your main screen,
these are the things,
these are the events
that you're tracking
that the users are doing.
From the main screen, they
may be going to another screen
and from those screens
they're doing other events.
These flow diagrams are
great to kind of visualize
how the users are
using your games.
And you can add steps
and scroll around
to actually visualize more or
less as you feel like doing it.
So the next thing,
the next group
that we were talking
about, is Revenue.
At the Revenue we actually
let you track revenue
at two levels.
And again this is optional.
You don't necessarily have
to send us your real revenue.
We're not after your data.
This is really
about helping you.
So you select.
If you choose not to send
us revenue, perfectly fine.
If you choose to multiply or
divide your revenue numbers
by something, perfectly fine.
You decide what data you want to
share with Google to help you.
Nobody is actually
looking at your data.
It's really only you looking at
this data in your own report.
But still if you want to
be paranoid and say, look,
I don't want to
really send revenue.
Well, send us hits
with zero revenue
because it will
count as conversions
and then you could do the
analysis on the conversions.
If you send us
revenue, it will help
you monetize different
items differently, right?
Like all of you probably have
different items in your game
that you sell.
Well, if you actually
send us the revenue,
then you could see how
different items are working out.
So in this example,
I'm actually sending
in two pieces of information.
I'm sending in a transaction,
which is the top part.
A transaction, think
of this something
as whatever you would send to
the app store or Play Store.
You would say, hey
this user came in
and they bought stuff
worth this much.
We do have
multi-currency support,
so you can actually
send in the currency
that you're doing
the business in.
Now the second
piece is the revenue
for individual line items.
Some of you might have actually
packages that you send.
You might say, hey,
I grouped these items
and here is a thing
that you buy in bulk.
You can actually send
us multiple line items
with a single transaction
or single line items.
Now once you do that,
you unlock the reports
that actually show you
revenues by different products
and by transactions.
So in this particular
example, I'm
showing that there is
two different items
that our app sells.
There is the bombs
and the magic potions.
And you can actually see that
the revenue for both of them
is about the similar, even
though the individual prices
are double, one is
double the other.
So you could choose
this information
to say, look, maybe
potions are not as popular,
I should maybe make it cheaper.
Or maybe I need to
make the bombs more
expensive because
everybody's buying them.
This allows you to
do a lot of analysis
of the relative values of
different items for you.
OK, the last piece.
The last piece is the
Custom Dimensions.
This is the data that
you have that you
might want to use later to join
this data-- join our Analytics
data with other data.
Think about this
as-- Rahul earlier
talked about dimensions.
Think about these
as extra dimensions
that you can send us
at different levels.
Some of you might actually
send them at the user level.
This could be the key that
you use to identify your user.
Now one thing I will
stress which is we
don't want anything PII.
If it is a key, it
should be a key to you.
We do not want the email
addresses or credit card
numbers or anything like that.
But it could be your key
that means nothing to Google,
and that's perfectly
fine because we're
considered a third party.
That key can mean
everything to you,
it just can't mean
anything to us.
And that's how we
define PII, which
is users' private information
that you would not
want to share with third party.
Think about what
your users would
be comfortable you sharing
with a third party.
Despite the fact that
nobody's looking at that data,
you shouldn't-- Send your keys
that are random numbers to us
and that's OK.
Then you could use them
to do the drawings.
Now custom dimensions,
we actually
have a 2-step process for these.
Step 1, you actually
define the custom dimension
in our configuration interface.
The reason behind
this is we don't
want to just call them
Custom Dimension 1 or 2 or 3.
We really want to
use the terminology
that you're familiar.
If you're sending
in a unique ID,
we want you to be able to
call that unique ID everywhere
in our reporting interface.
So the two things you do
is you tell us the name
and then you tell us what level.
You can tie things to sessions.
You can tie things to users.
Or you could tie
things to product.
The things where this
can be very useful
is if you're running
specials, you can actually
send in product level
information and go,
oh, this product was bought
as part of this special,
so later you could do analysis
on how different specials
applied to different products.
Once you actually
defined it, here
is how you actually
send a snippet.
And this is simple enough
that I can actually
show you both Android
and iOS in one slide.
It's really just the one line.
It's setting the
Custom Dimension
and then sending
a value with it.
So in this example, I'm sending
the #CRM ID as Custom Dimension
1.
And once you have done this,
you actually send this data
to Analytics, and this
will be a label to you
as your unique ID dimension
everywhere in Analytics.
Now, how do you actually take
advantage of all this data
that you actually sent to us?
For that, I'm going to
hand it over to Mike.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE KWONG: Thank you, Snehal.
So great, now that we
have this wonderful data
about your game in
Google Analytics,
let's take a look to see how
we can take advantage of it.
Let's start by
thinking about how
we can do analysis of the
data to get us some insight.
I'm going to focus on a
very important analysis
technique which is segmentation.
Google Analytics has very
sophisticated support
for segmentation.
You can define segments for
users, segments for sessions.
You can define segments just
about based on any Google
Analytics dimensions and
metrics that you can think of.
Revenue, device type,
even custom dimensions.
Once you've defined
these segments
you can apply them to
any reports at any time.
You can even use
more than one of them
together to try to
compare between them.
So to define a
segment is actually
very easy within
Google Analytics.
You can go directly to the UI
and use the segment editor.
Some might say it's
so easy that even
Rahul would be able to do this.
[LAUGHTER]
As you can see, there
actually are a number
of predefined segment
types that you can actually
choose from based on
demographics or even things
like the first date of
visit by the visitor.
But you have more
sophisticated needs,
you can actually
create a lot more
that conditions out of
all of Google Analytics
dimensions and metrics
and combine them
in very sophisticated ways.
In this slide we've actually
shown a user segment,
focusing in on users that
actually spend more than $30
within the game.
And we've called the segment
Highly Monetized Customers.
Now that we have
the segment defined,
we can actually apply it to
the Google Analytics reports.
Let's suppose we want
to look at the user
behavior for this
set of customers.
We can go to the User Overview
Report, apply the segment,
and then figure out, for this
set of users that have actually
spent a lot of money
within the game,
how many sessions
do they come back?
What's the their behavior?
What's their conversion
characteristics?
One thing that's very
useful about segment
is to kind of prove or disprove
hypotheses that we might have.
Let's suppose I'm
suspecting, I have a hunch,
that customers that convert
actually spend a lot of time
within the game.
How do I know if that's true?
One way to see that is to go
to something like the Loyalty
Report.
Apply the segment.
That way we can actually look
at the number of sessions
a user came back and
other characteristics
such as the average
amount of time
the user spends per
session within the game.
That might help me understand
whether my hypothesis
or hunch is actually
correct or not.
This is a very
powerful technique,
and for those of you
that haven't tried it,
I would highly recommend it.
So great, we can apply segments
and gain a lot of insight
about our users using
Google Analytics.
What else can we do?
What we want to be able to do
is actually take that insight
and actually act on them.
Rahul actually showed a
slide dividing up the users
into different buckets,
some users that
may have spent a lot of
money, some of them that
may be engaged.
Our goal, of course, is
we would like to actually
turn more of these
users into customers.
So how can Google
Analytics help with that?
Google Analytics has a lot of
useful data that you've sent,
so that's absolutely
something that we
want to be able to leverage.
But you can actually
do more with it.
You may also have other sources
of data, things such as CRM
systems or whatnot that may
contain a lot of other very
useful data about
your users that you
want to kind of
combine together.
There are many ways
of getting data
into and out of
Google Analytics.
I'm not going to go into
detail to most of these.
If you're interested,
please do come by our booth,
Booth 218, and find
us and we'll be
happy to talk to you
a lot more about them.
But I do want to point out at
least one way of accomplishing
this goal.
And that will leverage
the custom dimensions
that Snehal talked about,
that he instrumented,
about the unique
IDs of your users.
And I'm going to show you how
you can do analysis with it
and also export some
useful information out.
So given that I want to
convert users into customers,
one possibility
is for me to focus
on the users that are currently
not spending a lot of money
within the game but
are highly engaged.
So to identify them
I can once again
define a segment, which is
pretty much the inverse of what
I showed you before.
But in this case,
I'm going to identify
users that have spent
a little bit of money
but not a whole
lot, so basically
users that have spent between
$0 and $30 within the game.
And I'm going to call this
segment Potential Spenders.
The next thing
that I actually did
is I created what we call
a Custom Report, which
is a feature within
Google Analytics that
allow you to select any
Google Analytics dimensions
and metrics that
you're interested in
and generate a report out of it.
In this case, what I selected
is actually the unique ID--
the custom dimension that Snehal
actually already instrumented
the game to do-- along with
some metrics such as sessions
and also in-app revenue.
If I apply the segment
that I showed you,
we can then identify the list of
users that actually have spent
some money but not a
whole lot within the game.
Now I also actually further
subset this set of users
and find out which ones of them
are actually highly engaged.
I can modify or create a
new segment to do that,
but I'm actually going to show
you a different technique.
What I'm going to
do is actually apply
an additional filter
in this custom report.
And I'm going to
ask GA to only show
the set of users that
actually have spent at least
50 sessions within the game.
And if I apply
this filter, now I
have the list of
users that actually
have spent a little bit of
money but not a whole lot,
but is very engaged in the game.
I can then use the UI
to actually export out
the list of users
very easily, simply
by going to the Export
drop down and selecting
the format that
I'm interested in.
So in this case we
selected CSV file.
The CSV file will
contain all the users
that actually fall
into the bucket
that we're interested in
with some of the key metrics
that we've selected.
With that, you can actually
join that with data outside,
for instance in your CRM
system, and do further analysis.
You can even take
this list of users
and try to target
them within your game
with things like better
weapons, better spells,
and see if you can entice them
to actually pay and become
actually a more active
customer for you.
So I've shown you how
you can do this manually.
There are ways to leverage
this data in a programmatic way
as well.
For those of you interested
in how to do that,
please do come by
our booth, Booth 218,
and we can talk a
lot more about it.
So with that, I'm going to
turn the stage back to Rahul
to wrap up.
[APPLAUSE]
RAHUL OAK: Thanks Mike.
So I'll just do a quick
recap of what we went over.
So the problem here
was that initially you
saw those three people lonely
in the top right quadrant.
See, there is so many more
now, they look happier.
This is the end goal.
This is what we wanted to do.
And Snehal and Mike talked
over specific techniques
within Google
Analytics, using which
you can collect good
data, analyze it, and act
upon it to hopefully
achieve this end goal.
And before I leave the
stage, though, there's
one thing that I want
to definitely emphasize.
This morning, Russ
and Jonathan spoke
about this new, exciting
launch that we are coming up
with where you'll get
all the power of Google
Analytics inside the AdMob UI.
And I just want to stress
that it's the same.
Everything that we
spoke about, all of this
is available inside,
directly inside AdMob.
So we'd definitely love
you to try that out.
And that's it.
Thanks again.
Have any more questions,
we'll be hanging out
here or at the booth over
the next couple of days.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]